is the oracle's guardian serif an angel
were kid and commander locke both
casualties of war following the matrix
revolutions how did the analysts rise to
power these are all questions that could
be answered in future spin-offs
though trinity is killed at the end of
the third matrix movie she and neo get a
new chance at life in the matrix
resurrections as it's later revealed
that the machines resurrected both of
them in order to support the analysts
version of the matrix furthermore
trinity goes through a major development
in the film when she learns that she too
now has the powers of the one while the
first matrix does provide some clues to
trinity's past explaining that she was
once a master hacker not much else has
been revealed about her early days but a
prequel could do a lot to fill in those
blanks carriane moss has even teased
some of her own ideas about trinity's
origins in interviews for example she
told gq that she believes the character
was freed from the matrix at an early
age trinity's greatest hacking triumphs
could be depicted in this spin-off along
with her many encounters with agent
smith who in revolutions claims to have
failed in capturing her more than any
other human alternately while it's
almost a certainty that trinity would be
the co-star of any potential follow-ups
to resurrections that doesn't mean she
couldn't star in a solo sequel adventure
too
originally portrayed by lawrence
fishburne morpheus is a character who
captures viewers attention every time
he's on screen and often when he's not
the captain of the nebuchadnezzar is
everything you'd want from a leader wise
warm strong and never without hope
without morpheus faith in the one neo
might never have been freed from the
matrix and it's that same belief that
prevents further bloodshed in zion after
he realizes neo and the machines have
allied against ancient smith that same
faith however can also be somewhat of an
achilles heel for morpheus in the matrix
resurrections niobiu explains that it
caused him to underestimate the looming
threat of the analyst while
resurrections suggests morpheus was a
casualty of the ensuing machine attack
the movie sees neo create a youthful ai
version of his mentor played by yaya
abdulmatin ii
at last
the great thing about a possible
morpheus spin-off is that there's
already a fair amount of backstory to
work with elements from his past
mentioned in the matrix comics could be
expanded one along with the beginning of
his relationship and falling out with
niobi not to mention his time as high
chair of the zion council similarly the
origins of abdul mateen's half morpheus
half smith replica could also be
explored and a post-resurrection
spin-off starring that version of
morpheus has a lot of promise too
niobe is one of the undeniable standout
characters of the matrix sequels and one
of the patron saints of the matrix
spin-offs thanks to her star turn in the
2003 video game enter the matrix a
fearless leader with a calm yet
commanding presence she remains by far
one of the best contenders for a matrix
spin-off being the only character from
the original resistance to appear in the
matrix resurrections other than trinity
and neo naobi has a wealth of story
possibilities worth exploring a spin-off
starring the character could explore her
early days in zion or the original
matrix or it could reveal in detail the
events that occurred between revolutions
and resurrections more specifically it
might focus on the formation of io
zion's successor and niobe's rise to
become its leader
true to his name ghost doesn't appear as
often as his captain naobi in the second
and third matrix movies but he gets an
enormous amount of screen time in enter
the matrix in which he and niobi are the
two playable characters an avid student
of philosophy with a wry sense of humor
and an otherwise no-nonsense demeanor
ghost would be a great candidate for
more matrix spin-offs a prequel series
to the original trilogy could show how
ghost ends up joining niobe on the logos
and how he becomes such an expert shot
as well as the origins of his unrequited
crush on trinity conversely a spin-off
set after the first three films could
reveal what happened to him in the more
than 60-year gap before resurrections
including how he handles the news of
trinity's demise perhaps his heroics in
revolutions even earn him a ship of his
own
the matrix's most notorious agent smith
proves you can't keep a bad program down
in resurrections in which he's
reincarnated as a new identity as thomas
anderson's boss and business partner
smith and neo's mutual hatred of the
analyst leads the two to briefly join
forces near the movie's end and the
notorious agent lets his own boss know
exactly how he feels by filling him with
bullets once smith has accomplished his
objective he leaves neo and trinity to
be hunted down by the analysts legion of
bots you know the difference between us
tom
anyone could have been you
or as i've always been anyone
this begs the question where did he go a
smith spin-off could answer that
question showcasing his activities after
resurrections just what plant will he
come up with next to fight the architect
and keep his freedom will he be a friend
or a foe when neo and trinity decide to
remake the matrix that they promised to
do at the end of resurrections while
future matrix movies would likely answer
those questions a spin-off could surely
delve further into the details another
option would be to explore smith's
activities in the previous version of
the matrix from the original trilogy
which could allow hugo weaving to return
to the role better yet a smith project
could go back even further in time
revealing whether or not the earlier
iterations of the matrix included a
version of smith to balance out their
versions of the one a subject of much
debate among fans
buggs is the captain of the nemacini in
the matrix resurrections as well as the
red pill who frees neo from the matrix's
latest reincarnation brave good humored
and not one for following orders when
she feels they're wrong bugs would be a
perfect candidate for a matrix spin-off
given how her matrix extraction occurs
not long before she does the same for
neo it wouldn't be necessary to de-age
the character digitally for a prequel
provided it focuses on bugs as a young
adult be it a prequel or a sequel
however jessica henwick could easily
slip back into the role and
resurrections shows that bugs is well
known for heading out on solo missions
too that said the spin-off could also
spotlight her nemasceni crewmates to
flesh them out further more clearly
establishing how each of them relates
with their captain
though purged from the matrix sometime
before resurrections the oracle is far
from forgotten morpheus tells neo in the
matrix that the oracle has sided with
zion since the human rebellion began
however the architect reveals in
reloaded that her existence extends back
even further as she helped him create
the first successful version of the
machine's simulated reality given that
there have been seven versions of the
matrix and the initial two failed the
oracle might have been around as far
back as the third matrix meaning she has
a wealth of backstory ripe for
exploration a prequel spin-off starring
the oracle could answer many
long-standing mysteries such as what the
other iterations of the matrix were like
how she met her bodyguard serif and when
she first rebelled against the architect
it could also feature neo's predecessors
since each matrix the oracle co-created
also contained its own version of the
one the character would likely be recast
as her original actor gloria foster
passed away while her second actor mary
alice hasn't worked in entertainment
media for some time not that a sequel
spin-off is out of the question however
the merovingian does explain in
revolutions that the oracle can give her
eyes to others could she have passed
them on to a successor
the matrix movies have dropped countless
hints about the mysterious program known
as seraph in the matrix revolutions he's
referred to as wingless by one of the
merovigian's enforcers the mirv himself
even reveals later on that the two have
a past association while it's unclear
whether seraph ever actually had wings
this clue as well as his white costume
and biblical name suggests he may have
at one point been an angel within the
matrix this theory is further supported
when the merovingian calls him the angel
without his wings in french seraph may
even be a seraphim who were once the
agents of the paradise matrix
interestingly he almost starred in what
became the matrix path of neo video game
though that story wasn't to be it
doesn't mean serif can't get another
chance at a spin-off in addition to
examining his true nature and past with
the mirabenjian the spin-off could
uncover why seraph is absent from the
first matrix movie despite the oracle's
claim that he's been her bodyguard for
some time it could also depict his
battles with agent smith whom in
revolutions serif claims he is defeated
in the past
you do not truly know someone until you
fight them
neo is always shown to be uncomfortable
with the hero worship he receives from
many of zion's inhabitants which is one
of the reasons he finds kid particularly
difficult to be around since meeting neo
on the day he freed himself from the
matrix kid has idolized humanity's
prophesized savior and he clearly states
his intention to one day serve aboard
the nebuchadnezzar a prospect nobody on
the ship is too thrilled about still he
proves to be a pretty remarkable person
himself in zion's battle against the
machines by helping captain mafuni
reload while fighting off sentinels
after a timely save from z he also gives
the hammer the opening it needs to
re-enter zion kid appears in the matrix
online afterwards helming a ship
fittingly called neo's hope oddly he's
not present in resurrections despite
being significantly younger than most of
the major characters in the first three
movies it's possible he was one of the
many casualties from the machine's
renewed war on zion of course but nobody
can know for sure a spin-off could
easily tie up this loose end however and
show kid further coming into his own as
a hero after revolutions
jason locke is introduced in the matrix
reloaded as morpheus's opposite he's a
hardened pragmatist who neither believes
in the one nor has any love lost for
morpheus the man who once dated his
lover naobi though arguably an effective
tactician and leader of zion's forces in
the real world locks disdain for
morpheus and his beliefs often cloud his
judgment causing him to repeatedly
underestimate neo's importance in the
war against the machines though he
becomes an important figure in the
matrix online lock is not seen in
resurrections suggesting his
relationship with naobi at one point
ended for any number of reasons perhaps
even his demise a spin-off featuring him
could shed some light on his fate and
reveal whether or not his contentious
relationship with morpheus improved
after neo saved zion it would also be an
opportunity to humanize locke and make
him more sympathetic as he is somewhat
of an antagonistic figure in the
original matrix trilogy
who better to tell the full story of the
matrix than the two programs who've seen
them all the architect alone created six
versions of the matrix aided by the
oracle in the later versions a spin-off
starring him or both characters could
feature every iteration showing how they
changed over time though the architect
himself is certainly not an action hero
he would have both the seraphim and the
agents to back him up on his adventures
facing off against the ones who existed
before neo this spin-off could also
address whether the architect himself
changed with each new matrix iteration
in the original paradise version for
example could he have looked or dressed
more like artistic depictions of the
judeo-christian god similarly could the
oracle's appearance have resembled that
of oracles of classical antiquity like
those found in ancient greece the
analyst meanwhile has only created the
seventh matrix but that doesn't mean
he's not worthy of a spin-off of his own
perhaps such a film could show how he
overthrew the architect in the first
place this would also provide a good
opportunity to elaborate on events
referenced in resurrections including
his mass purging of rebellious programs
which might give some much needed
closure for characters such as the
oracle ramachandra and kamala check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you